I have friends who make forty seven
thousand dollars a year and are the
happiest people I know their work life
balance is on point they're part of two
soccer teams they play video games they
watch every show they want they take two
vacations that they scrap together and
they're happy as hell and I know
tons of people who have hundreds of
millions of dollars in their bank
account and are as miserable and as
lonely and as broken as you'll ever see
seven billion people need to change the
conversation of what success looks like
it is not to make a billion dollars it
is to actually wake up in the morning
and be in a good mood